wir wollen aber nicht nur die höheren
die politik machen wir wollen auch die
höheren die politik betrifft und zwar
ganz direkt und dazu begrüße ich jetzt
hier in dieser sendung nicole genau sie
ist unternehmerin in der eventbranche
stefan olschewski hotelier und gastwirt
und ich begrüße angelegter hellstern
sie ist fitnessstudio betreiberin sie
drei sie kommen aus ganz
unterschiedlichen orten in deutschland
aus baden württemberg aus bayern aus nrw
aber sie einst dennoch 1 sie sind direkt
von den corona regeln betroffen und
darüber möchte ich jetzt mit ihnen
sprechen wie fassen sie diese neuen
maßnahmen jetzt auf frau gundel auf
vielleicht wollen sie anfangen
ja ganz gern ganz gerne
ich bin unternehmerin schon seit 27
jahren im eventbereich tätig tönis
überwiegend und das erste was ich
eigentlich sagen möchte ist dass dieses
exponentielle wachstum nicht stimmt weil
ich habe hier mal die man kann das
eigentlich alles herrlich angucken wenn
man sich das ist kein experte
potenzieller wachstum sondern dass es
eine wellenbewegung und ich bin immer
erstaunt dass es immer wieder darauf
hinausläuft dass wir einen unglaublichen
wachstum haben es werden neue zahlen
veröffentlicht auch gestern wieder dass
es so viele tote gibt wenn man auf das
die die intensivbetten register schotter
werden die toten ja auch angezeigt wann
es gestern 136 zum vortag und ich bin
wirklich schockiert dass diese
angstmache immer weitergeht stadt die
zahlen in die relation der vorjahre zu
stellen
heraus schewski lassen sie uns darüber
sprechen sie sind gastwirt sie sind
hotelier die maßnahmen die jetzt er
wieder gefasst wurden jetzt umgesetzt
werden die verlängerung des lok downs
wie schaffen sie das auf wenn man das
zweite mal am boden ist wieder
aufzustehen und das wieder unter
kontrolle zu bringen
obwohl mit den gesetzlichen wieder gute
rennen gefahren haben fast hingekommen
sind auch 19 uhr wie ich gestern auch
der kollege tim mälzer gesagt hat es
müssen jetzt die zugesicherten zuschüsse
kommen jetzt und nicht verschoben erst
hieß es am erst dann ist es am 15
am 25 ist ja online antrag zum antrag
zuschüsse erst gestellt worden wird
erfahren dass es im dezember weitergeht
aber nur irgendwann mal muss was kommen
sonst sind alle kollegen inklusive uns
dann natürlich auch am boden
frau ashton ihre vor sprecher empfinden
das ganze auch als panikmache fordern
dass jetzt auch mal unterstützung kommt
sowie fassen sie die lage derzeit auf
also ich sehe ganz anschließen was
eigentlich auch für mich ausschlaggebend
ist ist es fehlt mir eine
nachvollziehbare begründung warum
ausgerechnet betriebe wie zum beispiel
meine fitness anlage schließen müssen
obwohl effektive kommt jene konzepte
vorgelegt wurden
technisch perfekt sind wir aus gestalt
und potenzielle infektionsketten
detailliert und wahrheitsgetreu
nachvollziehen zu können dann es fehlt
uns auch eine verlässliche perspektive
in der pole in der korona politik wir
können nicht im 14 tage rhythmus plan
aufmachen zu machen und nur geöffnete
studio können auch neukunden werben oder
gewinnen geschlossen studio verlieren
nach und nach alle kunden wir stehen so
ziemlich am boden wir sind ganz unten
zwischenzeitig angelangten und so weiter
geht
die branche hat über 200.000 mitarbeiter
viele stehen wirklich mit dem rücken
jetzt total an der wand wir haben unsere
alters unter unsere altersversorgung
quasi schon rein gebuttert viele haben
darin aufgenommen haben häuser belastet
wir stehen wirklich mit dem rücken an
der wand gewissen also nicht mehr weiter
dann kommen immer solche sachen und wir
haben wirklich viel viel gemacht mir
geben den bereich und wie gesagt auch in
der nachvollziehbarkeit herr als gehe
sie sind gast und hotelier auch hier
haben sie sicherlich sehr viel
investiert um den hygienestandards
gerecht zu werden geht es ihnen ähnlich
dass sie nicht verstehen können warum
dann trotzdem zu gemacht wird und auch
perspektivisch das ja erstmal so bleibt
ja also geben sagt wie gesagt wir
verstehen es überhaupt nicht wir haben
meines erachtens wirklich alles getan
dafür dass die leute auseinander gesetzt
werden dass die hygienischen
bestimmungen eingehalten werden
es ist auch nichts zu ohren gekommen es
war wirklich alles alles sicher und ganz
schlimm war es als man die
schließungszeit auf 22 uhr und auf 21
uhr runter gesetzt hat weil dann hat man
die leute dann möglich verleitet privat
weiter zu feiern
wobei sie bei uns absolut unter
kontrolle worden
ich möchte sie alle fragen wie schauen
sie in die zukunft frau genau beginnen
sie gerne
also das ist jetzt eine glas also unsere
stärkste was er tatsächlich weihnachten
silvester kann weil und darauf auch
sagen wollte dass du das nächste jahr
auf insofern hatten gehört dass diese
pandemie erst nach der arkane position
bekam und ich ich kann es ihnen nicht
sagen also jetzt ich hätte einen früher
fand ich eigentlich ganz gut märz/april
mal zur ruhe zu kommen mal zu
entschleunigen ich hätte nie gedacht
dass es sich so lange hinzieht und jetzt
muss ich sagen ich frage überhaupt gar
keine prognose mehr für die zukunft nur
wenn ich halt die zahlen und diese schau
ich mir als seit monaten an es sterben
täglich 2500 menschen im schnitt in
deutschland und ich finde halt die
zahlen müssen
relation gesetzt werden ganz wichtig
immerhin sagt frau merkel jetzt an und
mit und auch im radio wird jetzt an und
mit chronisch gesprochen
und wenn man dem doktor strecken darf
hat er angekündigt dass es völlig normal
ist wenn in der winterzeit die zahlen
der positiv getesteten sind ja nicht
infektiös steigen werden und ich mich
würde halt wirklich mal interessieren
und die zahl finde ich nirgendwo wie
viele menschen sind tatsächlich rein an
cupid 19 erkrankte im moment die finden
diese zahlen nicht da kann ich ihnen
gerne empfehlen auf bild.de zu gehen
dort sind diese zahlen unter anderem
veröffentlicht aber wir wollen jetzt
weitergehen wie geht es wie schauen sie
in die zukunft auf frau hellstern die
fitnessstudios sind beschlossen
weihnachten wird ein bisschen geöffnet
manchen mag das ja ein bisschen trösten
ich nehme an sie aber nicht die studie
an weihnachten aufzumachen das ist
indiskutabel weil es bringt uns nichts
bringt den kunden nichts und macht
eigentlich corona virus an weihnachten
pause oder sonst was wir sehen die
zukunft ziemlich schwarz weil wie gesagt
uns fehlen die ganzen neuzugänge im
frühjahr und werden die neuzugänge im
jetzt hier dann in vor weihnachten
es fehlen uns neuzugänge grundsätzlich
wir haben noch abgänge wir hatten jetzt
in dieser zeit wo offenbar genau zwei
neuzugänge der rest war eigentlich hier
nur abgänge im studiobereich leben davon
zwei 21 und 22 wird hat für die branche
sehr hat ich weiß nicht wie viel da
überleben und welche quasi leise vor
sich hin sterben
herr olschewski leise vor sich hin
sterben ist das auch etwas was sie
befürchten oder gehen sie mit optimismus
auch ins neue jahren in die
weihnachtszeit
naja optimismus ist ein ganz anderes
falsche wort glaube ich die frage ist
wir haben jetzt ein bisschen locker und
wir haben seit über drei wochen
geschlossen in die zahlen steigen weiter
ich weiß nicht wo die herkommen
wir haben alles dazu getan
das andere ist wir werden uns über diese
zuschüsse wohl bis dezember retten
können wir werden einen to go geschäft
mit anbieten im hotel ist es so dass
arbeiter bzw
geschäftsreisende kommen dürfen was
natürlich in der winterzeit ist
natürlich ein bisschen abflaut
vielleicht einmal ein gedanke zum mit
nach hause nehmen
der vielleicht in jedem kopf herumspukt
was ist denn wenn die bevölkerung
irgendwann mal es satt hat das sind es
nicht mehr mitmachen diese hinhalten
wenn die wirklich alle auf die straße
gehen und sagen so jetzt ist ein punkt
erreicht jetzt können alle nicht mehr
wir sind bild und wir liefern dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren